to get to the villages around Sun Milan
you have to pass a checkpoint this land
belongs to the Sauk fin agricultural
company here where local people used to
farm suck fin is growing oil palms
it's a massive monoculture that requires
large amounts of chemicals the company
calls this development in the middle of
it lives farmers see ma ma Tia in his
view the plantations are ruining the
environment and his livelihood
he says family members and local chiefs
forced him to lease his fields to suck
fin for decades hoping to profit from
the deal by receiving part of the
payment but for SEMA ma Tia it's been a
disaster the family that used to depend
on this plantation on this land we were
over over 50 in this village all now the
land is gone the money that they gave is
current and living conditions are
getting difficult for us some
environmental activists call what
happened here a land grab a hundred 20
kilometers away farmer Soros si has not
least his land he grows palm fruit
himself along with other crops the oil
palms bear fruit for 25 years but since
they can only be harvested three or four
years after planting it's a long-term
investment 90s Kenickie I decided to go
into oil palm production nine years ago
this will be my pension we can harvest
it until I die
his family is large and they can harvest
the fruit all year round what they've
garnered today earns them around 10
euros and the parts of the plants that
can't be used are made into natural
fertilizer these oil palms are
organically grown out of necessity
that's the back alley artistic way
Edward I don't use chemicals and besides
I don't even have money to buy any so we
rely purely on our own traditional
method
along side the palms he grows pineapple
and cashews they not only provide food
for his family the crop diversity is
also better for the soil today Soros si
has a visitor it's Mohammed Kamara from
the Dutch palm oil company natural
habitats the group produces its own
organic palm oil fruits but also buys
from the local farmers embarking on
their plantation and a form of
developing them should I use support
also your meal it's really really
advantageous how long does it take you
to grow a plantation and then starts
processing so we decided to go straight
to the farmers who already have
plantations and then a system developed
their skills ultimately they increase
their yield the company's oil mill is
close by oil palms are high yield giving
four times as much oil as sunflowers per
hectare that makes it cheap and widely
consumed almost every other product in
supermarkets from cookies to face creams
contains palm oil most of the raw oil
pressed here is exported but the amount
is just a fraction of that produced by
large companies can the organic coral
compete we can definitely compete with
them the reason being we have complete
different form of production we are
organic they are conventional and being
organic gives you a premium and a market
one thousand four hundred farmers like
Soros has say are part of natural
habitats network of certified organic
growers their number is set to rise as
world demand for palm oil continues to
climb